[Music]
welcome to AI the future of us a podcast
Style video series that explores the
ways AI is shaping our feature and how
we can prepare for the changes that Leia
had I'm your host ferratakina and today
we are joined by Bruno Aziza who is head
of data analytics at Google Cloud
before being here today Bruno thanks for
having me for that
see I know that you speak to a lot of
you know customers and you know you have
been leading the data ethics at Google
Cloud but before we get there could you
share some of the key AI developments
that you've witnessed during your career
absolutely you're right I spent a lot of
time with customers and I remember
working uh in this field very very long
time ago in 2001 you know the business
subjects we are writing language
recommendations as the an output of a
dashboard so definitely there's been
tremendous amount of progress since 2001
I mean you could see technology like
narrative science today our grid
Partners in thoughtspot and then of
course all the development you've seen
in gen AI you know I think the main
developments are around the same goals
right the four key goals to think about
the first one is increase efficiency and
productivity you want to use gen AI to
automate tasks so you want to reduce
costs right and save money on on certain
costs that are you know taking uh time
away from your most valuable employees
you want to improve customer service we
see a lot of these uh use cases I know
we'll talk about detailed use cases here
and then finally you want to increase
Innovation you know these applications
have the ability to generate new ideas
that is great companionship with
information worker now what's amazing
you know over the last six months or so
you might have heard about examples like
companies like Telus or Accenture of
Wendy or Cartier that are all innovating
in the space that is really exciting I
know we're going to talk about use cases
but just give you a specific example
Accenture you know company I interviewed
about six or eight months ago about
their Alice program Alice stands for
Accenture legal intelligence contract
where they take over a million legal
contracts or run it through uh their
artificial intelligence programs to
translate the obligations that Accenture
might have so lawyers now you can get to
uh you know the the bottom line a lot
faster you know they've helped over 2
800 professional globally to deliver
faster uh value to their customers with
the use of AI and so definitely we've
gone a long way from 2001 when I was
trying to get dashboard outputs in human
language to my end users
and singular and it is interesting to
see where we have gone through you know
within the changes in the ecosystem
within the past two decades and like so
our centers and others how they're
really leveraging the technology that is
being you know today as well now I'd
like to focus a little bit on the you
know some of the challenges or Bridging
the Gap between the data ethics and
machine learning in essence and in your
opinion what are the main overlaps that
you see for two traditional separate
disciplines data science and machine
learning coming together
so I'd actually argue that these
disciplines are not separate they're
highly correlated right when I was at
Alpine day labs this is an AI workbench
company we just talked about Gago
garbage in garbage out right in the
output of your model so highly
predicated by the quality of the input
the input data quality of the data but
also the data that you train your your
models on so I know it's not a super
sexy topic to talk about the quality of
of the data but that is the foundation
that most of these models stand on right
I mean it's great to have a great model
of course but if the data is not
reliable
um you know there isn't much that's
coming out of it that's of a lot of
value now this is not a new topic either
if you if you Google the dimensions of
data quality you'll find I think a paper
that goes back to 1991 from MIT that
talked about the 20 dimensions of of
data quality now I'm not going to take
you through all of them but I will tell
you if you're listening to us there's
probably three big questions that you
should ask yourself and they kind of
spell this nice acronym rat rat one is
is your data reliable is it complete
fresh rich and secure is it actionable
meaning is it something that's relevant
to the end users is it trustworthy and
is it timely can you understand it is it
actionable does it get to you on time
and so the connection of high quality
data that's relevant actionable timely
with strong models that are trained on
data you can track you can trust is
really how you're getting these two kind
of uh what looks like separate uh topics
or separate disciplines that gets them
to come together
I agree with you right and your machine
learning is really as good as your data
as well so you really need good quality
data to be able to get you know good
quality model out for the end of the day
but you know and on the other side what
are the most pressing considerations
surrounding AI development and news that
you see as well
yeah there's there's quite a few I think
you know the first thing is ai's been
around for many years right I mean we do
have a ton of of discussions around AI
today but we've used it for a very long
time around us and then second you know
the place where AI is most helpful is
when it's supplied so I would try to
think about if you're uh in the
Enterprise today if you're a data leader
think about what your principles around
how using gen AI uh should look like now
we have a great paper from uh Neil who's
uh the VP of data platforms at Walmart
and sharing how he thinks about it and
if I were to summarize it you know it
probably again would come to a simple
acronym to remember in one of my friends
uh Andy goodsman's actually helped me
out with this acronym spell starmax so
how do we think about gen AI T is for
trustable and there are many dimensions
of trust right so you got to think about
privacy you got to think about
reliability Fidelity of the data instead
of fairness of the data so T is a really
important aspect then you got to think
about the a the applied aspects uh it
needs to be applied to the workflows
right it's not very useful if you have a
geni application that is not integrated
within the workflow so it just takes you
away from the action R is for recency
right so the ability to use data that's
recent not data that's
happened five years ago two years ago
you won data from yesterday is really
important in making helping you make the
right decisions m is multimodal the best
models will input of course text Data
images code and we'll respond exactly
the same way so this idea of having
multimodal applications really important
and then C is contextual what we're
doing here throughout you know we're
having a conversation you remember what
I said before and we continue it's an
expectation of an egi application is
that you need to make sure that it's
staying with the context so you don't
have to repeat yourself which could be a
lot of frustration so I know this might
be a long acronym so I'll make it simple
for you when I think about ai ai stands
for artificial intelligence but also
stands for applied applied to the
workflow and in a way invisible right
because it is contextual because it
feels like it's following you in a way
you almost stop realizing that is a is a
gen AI application
I like your acronyms but then I totally
agree as well uh in in respect to you
know it should be really unbiased as
well right so it is as if how you train
your child you know you want to give the
you know most unbiased information and
they'll really become that person you
know going forward but also we know that
there are also challenges applying you
know and using J2 AI as well you know
the we see a lot of you know data
analytics professionals also coming into
and becoming part of this and what are
the main challenges that you see for you
know the day da Professionals in
particular in terms of gen Ai and also
do you think that we'll have data
scientists data Engineers data analysts
machine learning engineers and you can
just take the you know number of persons
that we have what roles do you think
that they'll be playing in the future
yeah so I think it's a great question
because it could be very confusing today
you're probably getting questions from
your cios or chief data officers if
you're if you're a data analytics
professional today you know what are all
the things I can do and I was just
reading a paper by Mackenzie that was
showing the 22 use cases uh for Janae
applications and I think I can get a
little confusing because it you know
theoretically there's an infinite amount
of tasks you can think about so what I
would do is if I were you think about
this idea of jobs to be done what are
the verbs that you're trying to enable
inside your organization where your
genie application can become a co-pilot
of your work and so there's probably
eight verbs that I can come up with I'm
sure there's more but I'll give you a
sense of how they feel first one is
create right your applications can help
you create new content and they can
co-author new content with you second is
summarize large body attacks it can
fairly effectively summarize you have to
double check if course don't just go
with the summary just raw the way it's
giving it to you it can help you find
better it can help you review better it
can help you analyze better it can help
you explain better certainly in the case
of business intelligence you know the
the use of natural language uh can help
you know democratize the explanation of
particular dashboards reports that
otherwise would have been fairly hard
for regular information workers to
understand they help you recommend and
they help you support so those are kind
of the eight verbs I'm sure there's more
I'd love to see in comments what you all
think but think about that don't just
think about the specific tasks think
about the grouping of these tasks
because then it helps you explain better
to your management the rest of the team
what is it that you're working towards
well I love your eight verbs actually so
it looks like the you know the ecosystem
will will slightly change it is not it
is going to be more evolving in a sense
right and then with that so
what value does the Gen AI bring to
organizations you know with with your
experience and you know I know that as I
mentioned at the beginning as well you
do work with lots a lot of customers and
organizations you know where do you see
the most value
yeah there's a few areas where you know
as we said at the at the beginning of of
this conversation you know the the key
values are around increasing efficiency
productivity reducing cost improving
customer service increasing Innovation I
would say there's probably three key
themes you got to think about as you
think about the value Vector uh for Gen
AI inside your your company you know the
first one that I would really think
about is make sure you explain to the
rest of the company it's not magic right
these models are pattern recognition at
a massive scale right and so it's
possible because now we have access to
all the plumbing that's required to make
this happen you know we have of course
the algorithm libraries but we've got
compute we've got storage at scale that
really enables you to do it but it's not
magic so be sure to remind people of
that the second one is it's not about
machines versus Humans it's about humans
with a machine that can do more than
humans without a machine and so it's
really about co-piloting versus
autopilot and the reason for why I'm
saying that is one of the things we're
discovering is that with really good
um gen AI applications you can run into
the risk of falling asleep at the wheel
because you're starting to relies on it
so much and become you know it becomes
so believable that you might how would I
say delegate almost too much to it so
you got to keep an eye on that where
you're really using the technology to
co-pilot and not autopilot the one thing
we've discovered watching people working
with these applications is there's
something
interesting happening this human type
companionship that if you're using these
applications it's actually a great way
to get feedback both ways so if you're
building content for instance you can
talk to the chat as a way to get maybe
additional information refine content
and so forth so interestingly enough
when you would think that it's really an
automated kind of relationship or
transactional warrant if you start
interacting with it by giving it
feedback and thinking about more as a
sounding board to the ultimate content
that you're creating it could give you
this companionship that sometimes is
hard for Content creators who are
starting with a blank page and feel
alone a little bit these Journey
applications actually can be very
helpful to you that's great I think the
you know what we can see is that the the
AI is really becoming the assistance to
you know different personas and
different organizations and really
helping us to become more productive to
get to the you know the point that we
really want to get to but I with that I
want to look you know look ahead and see
what Ai and business analytics really
means and what do you believe is the
most exciting potential for an air
application that we have yet to see with
the data analytics in mind
there's a lot to be excited about just
that we talked about at the beginning of
the conversation right it's around
efficiency productivity reducing costs
improving customer service increasing in
Innovation potentials now to be uh you
know clear about this you know we're
still experiencing a lot of of
innovation experimentation with it today
I think there was Recent research that
showed that only four percent of
organizations are in production today so
we're certainly bound to find a lot of
new use cases out there but if I just
think top of mind I think the first idea
around pouring through a lot of content
um more automatically a lot faster so
you can pick up the patterns I think is
where these applications are very
helpful so if you're a business analyst
for instance you're launching a Jenny
application course a large body of
content that otherwise would have taken
you a lot of time to go analyze is a is
a really key use case you can see this
across multiple Industries right you can
see in in healthcare for instance you
know where you can you know streamline
the discovery of of insights uh you can
improve Medical Imaging Discovery and
understanding you can see this in the
legal context as well and so there are
many many areas where you can take
advantage of this there's also on the
analysis side you know a topic we don't
talk a lot about is the ability to
create synthetic data as well as you're
trying to test theories and so forth and
you want to not do this on personal data
or data you don't have access to these
Genia applications can help you create
completely fake data that you can run
your experiments on so that's another
way to think about it both in you know
pouring through existing data that would
be a lot of time a lot of work for you
but also creating data that you can work
with as a way to experiment uh your
methodology and that would not expose
private data or data that's highly
protected those two examples are really
interesting one there's hundreds of them
across multiple Industries but certainly
across banking education life science
manufacturing Healthcare there are
hundreds of use cases that I'm sure we
bound to see a lot about and and
certainly see deliver a lot of value to
people listening to us today
I agree and we are really just seeing
the you know tip of the iceberg there's
tons of you know use cases to to be
identified I really like your you know
generating data really for different use
cases because gen AI as names are just
allows you to create lots of data sets
to experiment with as well and and my
last question around us and definitely
not the least so what advice would you
give to individuals and businesses
looking to prepare for the feature
whereby AI really plays a significant
role I'm hearing this a lot I'm seeing a
lot of Articles I'm talking a lot of
customers lots of professionals everyone
have this in mind right how I can
prepare myself how I can prepare my
organization that I'm still you know
valid you know in the coming years and
months as well
well the first thing I would say is that
be careful about getting enamored by the
marketing of many organizations are in
Italians solve all your problems uh with
these new applications I think you
really gotta study a little bit more
about the applications before you start
applying them uh in production and in
real life as in that's probably the
first thing like I said earlier it's not
magic and second is it is a co-pilot
it's not an autopilot it is technology
that can certainly be very helpful but
in the end you're making the decision uh
and you're needed to make that decision
because that's critical for how you're
driving value into your business and
then finally what I would say is get
trained experiment with as many tools as
many models as you can so you can see uh
how it feels and remember that the
quality of the data the quality input uh
the type of data you're training it on
is
as important if not more important as
the model itself and so you really want
to spend a lot of time on the
fundamentals those are now changing you
need to have high quality data you need
to connect your use cases to business
value and of course if technology in the
way between the data acquisition and the
data activation if there's you know
capabilities that can automate and
facilitate your job you should
definitely consider them but remember
you're in charge of the decision in the
end
yes and it is really an optimization
problem at the end of the day right so
whether you invest a lot of effort in
building your models or whether you are
using existing ones and high quality
ones how much accuracy is good for you
and whether you are really getting the
return on investment you know with the
skills that you are providing and with
the you know input that you're putting
into as well thank you for joining us
today Bruno it has been incredibly
insightful to hear your thoughts you
from your experiences as well and we
look forward to seeing how AI is going
to continue the you know the data
ecosystem around us and hope our viewers
will be inspired to embrace its
potential and opportunities thank you
very much
thank you for that
foreign
[Music]